hey everyone
welcome to another video by simply learn
in this video python data visualization
tutorial we will teach you everything
that you need to know about data
visualization in python
data visualization is the field
of representing data that you already
have in a visual form which makes it
easier for both you
and the user to understand it
python has mainly three main libraries
which help in data visualization
in this tutorial we will teach you
everything that you need to know about
these three different libraries and how
you can use them to visualize your data
better
to begin
we will start with the matplotlib
library
we will explain matplotlib to you
teach you about the different types of
plots
and how to plot different graphs and sub
graphs in matplotlib
we will also look at how you can include
graph parameters like titles legends and
labels into your matplotlib graphs
then we will move on to seaborn
we will explain what is c bond to you
and then understand python c c-bond
better with the help of a hands-on demo
feel free to follow along with it
and finally we will take a look at the
bokeh library offered by python which is
used to make interactive graphs in
python
we will explain different graphs like
scatter charts line charts pie charts
histograms bar plots etc in bouquet and
how you can implement them and make them
user friendly and interactive
and finally we will take a look at the
layout function in python which is used
to make
interactive web interfaces
so
let's get started we're going to study
the matte plot library and the python
code so what's in it for you what is
matte plot library types of plots
plotting graphs and sub graphs adding a
graph inside a graph graph parameters
title label legend line graphs line
types color and transparency canvas grid
and axis range 2d plots scatter step bar
fill between radar chart histogram
contour image 3d surface image and then
we'll hit a practice example pie chart
so let's start with what is matte plot
library map plot library is an open
source drawing library which supports
rich drawing types it is used to draw 2d
and 3d graphics
and there are so many packages in the
matplot library we're going to cover the
basics and there are so many packages
that sit on top of the maplight library
that we can't even cover them all today
but we'll hit the main one so you have a
good understanding of what the matplot
library is and what the basics can do
you can understand your data easily by
visualizing it with the help of matplot
library you can generate plots
histograms bar charts and many other
charts with just a few lines of code and
here we have some basic types of plots
you can see here that we'll go into we
have the bar chart the histogram boy i
use a lot of histograms in my stuff
scatter plot line chart
pie chart and area graph
let's start plotting them and to do this
i'm going to be using jupyter notebook
you can use any of your python
interfaces for programming or scripting
and running it of course we here really
like the jupiter notebook for doing
basic a lot of basic stuff because it's
so visual and in our jupyter notebook
which opens up in this case i'm using
google chrome you can go up here to new
and we'll create a new python 3 and set
that up
if you're not familiar with jupiter
notebook we do have a tutorial that
covers some of the basics of that you'll
look at any of our tutorials i usually
cover a number of them showing how to
set up jupiter and anaconda i myself use
jupiter through anaconda in fact let's
go ahead and open that up and just take
a look at this see what that looks like
you can see your anaconda navigator if
you install it it will automatically
install the jupyter notebook and that
also installs a lot of other things i
know some people like the qt console for
doing python or spider i've never used
them i actually use notepad plus plus as
one of my editors and then i use the
jupiter notebook a lot because it's so
easy to have a visual while i'm
programming and even simple script in
python i'll take it from the jupyter
notebook and then do a save as you
always go under file and you can
download as a python program so that
will download it as an actual python
versus the ipython that this saves it as
so let's go ahead and dive in and see we
got going here and let's go ahead and
put matplot library tutorial and i'm
going to turn this cell into a mark down
so it doesn't actually run it
you can see it has a nice little title
there that's all jupiter notebook
and then from matplot library
let's import
pi lab
back one and then let's go ahead and
just print
we'll go pi lab
and the version let's go ahead and run
this so we're going to import our pi lab
module from the matplot library and we
find out the word version 1.15.1
always important to note the version
you're in probably i was reading an
article that said the number one thing
that python programmers struggle with is
remembering what version they're working
in and making sure that they're going
from one platform to the other with the
same version and if we're going to graph
things i think we need some data to
graph so we're going to import numpy as
np now if you're not familiar with numpy
definitely go back and check out our
numpy tutorial there's so many different
things you can do with it dealing with
reshaping the data and creating the data
we're just going to use it to create
some data for us and there is a lot of
ways to create data but we're going to
use the np.line space
so we're going to create a numpy array
and the way you read this is we're going
to create numbers between 0 and 10 and
we're going to create 25 of these
numbers so we're just going to divide
that equally up between 0 and 10. and if
we have x coordinates we should probably
have some y coordinates and we'll do
something simple like x times x
plus two and let's just take a look
we're going to print x
and print
y
let me go ahead and run this
and let's see we got going on here so we
have our x coordinates which is 0 0.4
0.83 etc and you can look at this as an
xy plot so we have zero we have two so
we have
0.416 we have
2.17 and just as a quick reminder we're
going to do print np array x comma y dot
reshape 25 comma 2. and the reason i
want to do this is i want to show you
something here a lot of times a program
returns x comma y and it's an array of x
comma y x comma y x comma y
and so when you're working with the pi
plot
you have to separate it out and reshape
it so if i start off with pairs like
this i can reshape them if i know
there's 25 pairs in there i can switch
the 2 and the 25 and this is kind of
goofy but we'll do it anyways reshape so
i'm going to reshape my 25 by 2 back to
2 by 25
and if i run that you'll see i end up
with the same output as the x y the two
different arrays in here
and this is important that we want x and
y separate
again that's all numpy stuff but it's
important to understand that this is a
format that matplot library works with
it works with an array of x's and they
should match your array of y's so each
one has 25 different entities in it
and then for our basic plotting of this
data it only takes one command to draw
graph of this data and so we use our
from up here where we imported pi lab we
take our pi lab and the key net under
there is plot for plotting a line and
then we want our x coordinates and our y
coordinates and we'll throw in r and the
r simply means red so we're going to
draw the line in red let me go and run
that
you can actually switch this around if
you wanted to do different there's b
for blue we have a lot of fun yellow
hard to see yellow there we go but we'll
go ahead and stick with red
run
and when you're doing presentations with
these try to be consistent you know if
the business and the shareholders send
you a
spreadsheet and they have losses in red
use red for losses in your graph
try to be consistent use green for
profit for money you don't have to
necessarily use green but whatever
they're using whatever the company is
using try to mirror that that way people
aren't going to be confused if you
switch your data around every time one
graph has red for loss and one graph has
blue for loss it gets really confusing
so make sure you're consistent in your
graphs and your coloring and something
to know because we're going to cover
this in a minute this is your canvas
size so we have a canvas here and what
we're going to do next is we're going to
look at sub graphs okay
so let's take our pi lab and create a
sub
plot
and one of the things also to know when
we're working with the
matplot library i'm not setting when i
do this this is my drawing canvas the pi
lab so once i've imported the pi lab i'm
drawing my images on there very
important to know and with the subplot
we're going to give it some different
values and we're going to represent by
rows columns and indexes
and let's do one two one so it's going
to be the first row
second column and the index is like you
can stack your graphs and things like
that we don't worry too much about
indexes but rows and columns we want to
go ahead and use row one and column two
and if we're going to have one object we
should probably have two but before we
do that we have to
plot data onto the subplot so the order
is very important and we're going to
stick with our x comma y
and let's do this we're going to add in
a third parameter here remember we did
red we're going to add shorthand dash
dash for dash lines so this plots the
data into row one column two and if
we're going to do that let's do another
one pi
lab.subplot and if we're going to do row
one let's do
column two and index two
and this time we're going to add g for
green and this denotes a style and if
we're going to set up our pi lab subplot
there we go right lab we've got to go
ahead and plot that pi
lab plot
and instead of x y we want y comma x
oops i messed up this is in the wrong
spot there we go we'll move that down
here real quick because that goes in the
plot part so the subplot tells it the
row column and index and the pi plot
tells it what data in this case we
switched them and the color and then the
style shorthand now let's go ahead and
run that
and you'll see it takes this canvas
splits it in two and now we have two
different graphs and we have the red one
with dashed lines and we have the green
one which is has a little stars going up
and if we take this and let's just um
just for fun let's change this and run
that with an index of one it puts them
both on the same index and also gives me
a warning because it's a strange way of
doing two subplots there's depreciated
there's another way to do it but most
people just ignore that warning because
it's not going to go away anytime soon
now that's using the same setup what
happens if we do instead of
this let's change the column on here and
find out what happens
and if we do the column
it didn't really like that on the setup
it just disappears so let's keep our
column as two and let's change the row
on the second one to two
and run that
and you'll see again it kind of squishes
everything together and causes some
issues so let's take the index so these
need a unique index and you can see here
where i made some changes i said row two
and look what happens when i change to
column two so i now have row two column
two index 2. it squished it up here so
you could put another graph underneath
is what that does there's all kinds of
different things you really have to just
play with these numbers till you get a
handle on them because
you know we have to repeat 164 times
according to cambridge university if
it's completely new to you and you can
see right here where we go three
run there we go but you can see it takes
a little bit sometimes to play with
these and get the numbers right
hopefully hit the wrong one that's why
let's go three there three there run
there we go now it's overlapping so i
have this doubled over here on the right
for now we'll just go ahead and leave
this with the
where we have column and row two and the
two different indexes so they appear
nice and neatly side by side
and then as we just saw as we were
flashing through them we can put them on
top of each other
and let me just highlight that and copy
it down here
paste it down there and here we have one
two one and then we'll do one two one
also for this one and that puts the two
subplots directly on top of each other
gives us that warning and you can see we
now have two different sets of data
graphed on top of each other and you can
also see how it did the indexes since
one of them is from 0 to 10 that's the
green one on the x-axis and the other
one is from 0 to 10 on the y-axis so it
took the greatest value of either one
and then used those as a shared value
so let's
next look at operator description and
we'll go ahead and turn this cell into a
markdown and run that so it looks nice
so fig and you remember i talked about
the canvas earlier i briefly mentioned
it we're going to look a little bit more
at the canvas later on but that's what
the figure is fid we're going to add
axes so we're going to initialize the
subplot add the subplot
in rows and columns and all kinds of
different things with this you can do
let's look at that code and see exactly
what's going on and i want you to notice
that there's fig which is the actual
canvas in the matplot library and ax is
commonly used to refer to the subplots
so we're creating subplots you'll see ax
equals plt subplot
earlier we did the pi lab so let's go
ahead and import pi plot from matplot
library and we're going to do it as plt
you'll see that a lot that's really the
standard in the industry is to call it
plt just like pandas as pd and numpy
array as np certainly you could import
it as whatever you want but i would
stick to the standards and we're going
to do the same graph as we did above
with the pi lab but with the plt so if
it looks familiar there's reason we're
doing this because we want to show you
how the figure part works and working
with the canvas goes but we're going to
do the same plot as we did before and
we'll call it fig and we're going to set
that equal to plot figure so there's our
figure or our canvas on there and let's
create a variable called axes and we're
going to set that equal to fig dot add
axes
and in this we're going to control the
left right the width the height of the
canvas from zero to one
and so we can go ahead and i'm just
gonna put some stuff in there i got
point five point one point eight point
eight so when you're looking at this
this is a zero to one or you could say
fifty percent ten percent eighty eighty
percent but it's a control it's going to
control your left and your right along
with the width and the height so the
width and the height we're going to use
80 percent and we're going to have like
a little indent on the left and the
right and this should look familiar from
above x's dot plot
x comma y and then let's give it a color
how about red since we're recreating the
same graph let's keep it uniform oops
and it helps if i use a axis instead of
ax es i don't know where that came from
but this looks identical to the one we
had up above so here's our axis plot x
comma y of red
same graph same setup but this time
we've added a variable equal to the
figure dot add axes so our plot figures
our canvas our axis is what we're
working in and then our axis.plot x
comma y
and again we can draw sub graphs let me
put that down here
[Music]
just like we did before and a little
different temptation here we have fig
comma
axes equal
plt.subplots
and in here it's going to be the number
of rows
we're going to do one row
and columns equals 2. so if you remember
before this that we did we had one row
with two different graphs on it we're
going to do the same thing but know how
we did this here's our figure our canvas
and our axes we're going to create
actually two different axes we're going
to create row one column two and so axis
is an array of information so we can
simply do
4
let's do x in axes
this will now look familiar x dot plot
we're going to do x comma y we'll go
ahead and make it red
keep everything looking the same
remember nice uniform graphs everything
looks the same and if we go ahead and
run this
you'll see we get two nice side-by-side
graphs so just as we had before the same
look the same setup
and just for fun let's change in columns
to three we'll run that and now you see
we'll have three on there and let's even
make it a little bit more interesting
we'll do in rows equals to two and you
can see down here we're going to get an
attribute eric's is trying to scrunch
everything together so it does have a
limit how much stuff you can put in one
small space that's important to know you
can fix that by changing the canvas size
which we'll look at in just a minute and
there's other ways to change it on here
but here we go we can do in rows two and
columns equals one you can see two nice
images right above each other we'll go
back to the original one row two columns
side by side left to right and
we can also
draw a picture or graph
inside another graph
and that's kind of a fun thing to do
it's important to note that we can layer
our stuff on top of each other which
makes for a really nice presentation
so let's start by fig
create another figure so we're going to
start over again with our canvas we set
that equal to plt.figure
so there's our new canvas and let's do
axes we'll call it axes one and two axis
one equals fig dot add axes remember
this from earlier
and
this here similar numbers we used before
saying how big this axis is this figure
in the axes is so this is going to be
the big
axes and let's do axes 2 equals
another figure add axes and then point
two point five point four point three
and if we're going to do this they need
data on them so let's go ahead and plot
some data on our axes so axes one dot
plot
and we'll make this simply x comma y
comma make it red and then let's go axes
two dot plot
and let's reverse them y comma x comma
green there we go doing what i told you
not to do you shouldn't be swapping axes
around and plotting your data in five
different directions because it's
confusing let's go ahead and run this
and see what this looks like and then
let's talk a little bit about this we
talked about the 0.2.5.4.3
and let me just grab the annotation for
that that's left right width and height
so we have in here that this is going to
be left right so here's our left is
point one in point five and we you know
what let's just play with this a little
bit what happens when i change this to
point one moves it way over to the left
so there's our point one so we can make
this point four run that there we go so
you can see how you can move it around
the branches on here point two
point five is the
left so that's our right so see what
happens when we do point oh let's make
this point one that actually is they had
it down at left right i thought this was
wrong it's actually how far from the
bottom let me switch that on here bottom
there we go so we had here on this we
can go ahead and put that back to 0.5
and run that
and this is point three let's make this
point three also and that is the width
and then of course there's the height we
can make that really tiny actually let's
do point two let's run that and you can
see it changes the height on there we
make it even smaller 0.2 by 8.2 and as
you can see you can get stuck playing
with this to make it look just right it
can sometimes take a little bit
certainly once you have the settings if
you're doing a presentation you try to
keep it uniform unless it doesn't make
sense for the graph you're working on
try to keep the same colors the same
position and the same look and feel
and i mentioned earlier we can adjust
the canvas sides so this is from earlier
i just copied it down below we're going
to re-plot the same data we've been
looking at
and what we can do is we can change the
figure size to 16 by 9. let me run that
and show you what that looks like so it
fills the whole screen and then if you
are normally when you're working on the
screen you don't worry too much about
this but we can set the dpi
to 300
run that
there it goes this is your dots per inch
and if you are doing an output of this
and you're printing a hard copy you want
the higher quality i would suggest
nothing under 300 if it's a professional
print you might get a little less than
that but whenever i'm doing professional
graphics and printing them out on
something 300 dots per inch is kind of
the minimal on there you can go a lot
higher too but keep in mind the higher
you get the more memory it takes the
more lag time and the more resources you
use so usually 300 is a good
solid number to use your dots per inch
and you can see it drills a nice it
draws a nice large canvas here which is
16 by nine and then the dpi is 300 on
here it's a little higher quality and
just out of curiosity i wonder how long
it takes to draw something double that
size 600 and you can see here where at
600 dpi it's going to take a while there
it goes just because it's utilizing a
lot more graphics on there and let me
just go back to the 300 now we'll
actually do let's do a 100 you're not
going to see a difference on this
because it is web based graphics are
pretty low
and up here you saw i did this with the
plot figure this works the same if i do
figure axes subplot figure size and then
we'll go ahead and do axes
plot
x comma y comma we'll stick to red
let's go ahead and run this and you
should get almost the same thing here
here's our
axis on the subplot on here with the
fixed size and the dpi let me take this
all out let me just remove all that real
quick run it again there we go now we're
back to our original figure and let's
look at some of the other things you can
do with this
one things we do is we can set a title
for the axis so axis set title you'll
see right here since i put this on the
axis it's the main title for the whole
graph
and if you're going to have a title you
should also label so we can label our x
label and we can set our y label in this
case we're just going to call it x and y
keep it nice and uniform and if we run
this you'll see that we've added a nice
x label and y label whoops where'd they
go and it turns out in this environment
that you have to put it before the title
so let me go ahead and put it before the
title and there's our x y and then we
run that and of course we can also do
upper size a little bit you can see
what's going on a little better so here
we have x label x if you come down here
you'll see our x label and our y label
we can of course change this to x
label you can change this to y
maybe whatever you want on here of
course and our title graph there we go
run so here we have our title graph our
y label and our x label all set up on
our nice little plot and then before we
move on to the next section let's do one
more thing on here we have a thing
called the legend and we're going to do
we're going to set our ax legend label 1
label 2 up here it's a format for it but
let's go down here and actually use it
i'm going to do two different plots
we're going to have axes plot x by x
times x squared and x cubed and if i run
this you'll see it puts two nice graphs
on the setup on there but it's nice to
have a legend telling you what's going
on so for the legend we can actually do
axes since we have the two plots legend
and on here
we've created an array
and we have y equals x squared y equals
x cubed you can actually put this as
whatever you want those are just strings
and then location two and let's go ahead
and run this and see what that looks
like and you can see it puts a nice
legend on the upper left hand corner
location two we can do location three
and run it and it drops it down to the
bottom
location one i can't remember where
that's at there we go upper right so
each one of these is a number that
refers to the different locations on the
screen zero kinda have to play with them
or look them up to remember where
they're at but they do work it just kind
of moves around depending on where you
want your legend out on there so on this
section we cover the title of the graph
the y labels and legends this is we're
getting into some starting to look
really fancy here so we now have
something we can actually put out you'll
see the title the graph looks a little
fuzzy so i might in a web setup put the
dpi up a couple notches maybe put it at
200 100 might work fine just so you know
something to notice on here when you're
playing with these different things we
had our subplots dpi equals oh let's do
200 and see what that looks like
so you can see now it's a lot clearer
it's also larger so it's a nice little
feature you can throw in there with your
dpi dots per inch
so the next section is let's look at
some graph features we're going to look
at line color transparency size and a
few more things on here and oops i
forgot the main title so we have our
figure and our axis equals our plot and
subplots and i'm going to do a dpi
equals 150 so the graph comes out nice
and large and easy for you to see
let's go ahead and do three plots on
here we'll do x by x plus one so it's
just going to be a straight line plot
x plus x plus two
and axes dot plot
x x plus three this looks like we're
doing nearest neighbor setup or showing
how it uh located data putting your
lines on there between the nearest
neighbors there we go so it draws a nice
little graph with three lines on it one
of the things we can do is we can
control the alpha on this oops and you
can actually see the when they did these
lines it automatically pulls in
different colors for your setup so some
automatic automatic things going on in
there and a lot of times we do that
comma r where we're going to do color
equals red another notation on here
let's go ahead and run this now we have
a bright red line down there and with
the map plot library you're not limited
to red you can also use the one of many
different color references as you see
here with the pound sign one one five
five dd which just is just blue and we
can do the same thing with another color
on here which turns out to be green i
can just as easily do this green
blue oops there we go blue and run that
and you'll see here we have red blue and
green and what i want to do is i want to
make this we're going to set what's
called the alpha on this and we're going
to set this equal to 0.5
so this is halfway see-through when i
run this and it's almost going to look
pink because you can see through it and
let's change this just a little bit just
to make this kind of fun let's square it
there we go run it so now we have this
nice square that comes up and you can
see when it crosses it because i plotted
these two lines after it and they have
no alpha the red is behind those lines
or in this case pink because we did the
alpha halfway through so let's go ahead
and do this alpha equals 0.5 and oh you
know what instead of squaring it let's
take it to the 0.5 power that'll be kind
of interesting to see what that does
we'll just go to keep it squared there
we go and run that and let's go back and
look at this where it crosses over and
the first thing you see right here is on
the blue it's kind of light blue now you
can see how the two colors add together
you get almost a purple on there so i
can clearly see where the red cross is
the blue line and then the green just
blanks it over because i didn't do any
opaqueness no alpha on there so this is
great if you have lots of data that
crosses over and you need to be able to
track those lines better and we'll go
ahead and do this 0.5 and we'll run that
oops i did
equals 0.5 let me go ahead and run that
and so you can see right here now you
can easily see the red line how it
crosses the green and the blue down here
and if we want to we can do this as the
default is one it's solid so we can
change this all to point eight let me
just do that
oops fifty eight eight there we go run
oops i must hit a wrong button there let
me try that again i actually get rid of
a bracket and let's go ahead and run
that
and we come down here and look at this
you can still see where it passes behind
them but the green dominates and the
blue dominates because we're now at 80
instead of 50 percent when you can do
less that's kind of fun although at some
point the lanes kind of fade
so 0.5 is usually the best setting on
there we have a nice pastel here at 0.3
and you can easily see where they cross
over and just like you can play with the
colors we can play with line width and
you know let's do
let's try dpi 100 and see what that
looks like on my screen equals 100 and
we'll go ahead and just take our ax plot
let's do four of these lines just you
can see how they look next to each other
real quick here there we go
and if i run this they should all appear
the same it automatically does different
colors on there so let's do color equals
blue
forgot my quotation marks there we go
and we'll go ahead and just make these
all blue just for purposes of being nice
and uniform and then what i want to do
is i want to do the line width
width
equals
0.25
and let's just copy and paste that down
here
let's do equals one
about 1.5 and let's do one let's make
this equal to two let's see what that
looks like and we do that you can see it
goes from a very thin line a point five
a one are one point five and two which
is twice the width of the one and if
we're going to do different sizes we had
different colors we had our alpha scheme
let's take this whole thing here
let's paste it down here and do another
one
but instead of line width let's look at
styles and something to know here you
can actually abbreviate this with lw so
line width can also be point let's just
do everything point two and let's set up
a line style we'll do the first one
dashes and let me just paste that down
here
so i'm not doing a lot of extra typing
there we go
take this out so we have our dashed
we can do a dash dot we'll just do the
dash dot here and a colon here there we
go and there's a lot of different
options we'll look at a few more as we
go down for different ways of
highlighting data
but when you look at this we have
everything as a line width of two and
now we have a straight line we have a
dashed line or a dot dash and a dot dot
dot line
and then another thing we can add on
here is we're going to do here's our ax
plot and we did x let's do x plus
four so it goes right on the top and do
color black line width 1.5 so it's a
smaller line
and we're going to take the line and
we're going to set dashes so look i've
changed some of the notation here for my
line and my ax plot so i can set my line
comma equal to x plot and then i can
change the line settings this way and
when i run this let me run that on here
you'll see the 5 10 15 10
creates a series of dashes that are
varied in link link in this case they
alternate between a short dash and a
long dash we can play with these numbers
curiosity always has me what happens
when you play with the numbers just to
see what they look like let's do this
let's paste this down here i'll do two
of these just because they're kind of
fun to play with and let's change this
from 10 to
3 and we're going to change this one
from 15
to
four and let's run that
and you can see the differences in the
lines oops very a little bit confusing
on there because i forgot to change the
lines are all on top of each other so
let me change that really quick here and
let's run that and now you can see
here's our original dashed line
alternating when i change these numbers
on the second one the very end value to
three you can see now we have the dashes
of five let's see i'm gonna guess this
is a dash is a five skip ten dashes of
15 skip 3 and then it goes back to the
beginning dash is 5 dashes skip 10 15
dashes skip 3. and of course the last
one we just switched up a little bit it
looks a lot more uniform because i'm
using two sets of 10 or if i did
something like this and change it to 30
it really becomes pronounced as far as
the distances between them and instead
of 4 let's go oh let's put 30 here also
30 by 30. there we go really pronounced
on that one and let's look at one more
important group for plotting our data
and in this we're gonna here's our plot
we started with with the x plus one x
plus two x plus three and did it in blue
on this one's three or four different
blue lines
and this property we want to add the
actual plots so you can see where the
plots are on the graph and for that we
might have marker equals o and if we run
this let's see it puts a dot for each of
these and there's 25 dots because we
have 25 x values so we actually have
zero and each of the different values of
x y are then plotted here with the dots
and we don't want to just limit
ourselves to dots
you can also do
plus sign that's another option dots is
most common i'll actually like the dots
the best if we do the plus sign you see
it puts a nice crosshairs or plus sign
on there and we can do a marker there's
a number of different markers you can
use
and i think this one was it s is another
one
which is a nice square and that's
actually a good one that's for square o
for
period okay that's just kind of weird so
you can see that probably on these
markers another one is the number one so
if we run that you'll see we now have
these little hatch marks
and let's take oh let's just go with the
o on this one
by the way this works with square really
nicely some stuff we're gonna do here on
just a second let's do marker
size equals two and change that to five
and run that and you can see here it's a
nice little tiny dot versus uh this size
dot here this is interesting because it
said two i thought it would be bigger
but if you do 0.5 it gets even smaller
and let's just do 10 to see what that
looks like run that looks huge so marker
size a lot of these are dependent on the
dpi and the setups there's things that
switch around as far as the way the size
shows up you got to be a little careful
when you change one setting it can
change all the other markers and then
let's take our square on here
and we'll do we have marker size so we
also have marker face we'll set that
equal to red of course we need to take
change the so it's up one notch we'll
run that whoops must have mistyped
something on here and i did it's marker
face color equals red and so when i run
that you can now see i have the squares
on there with the marker face color of
course we can mix and match these
come down here and we'll make this
instead of let's make this plus seven
and we'll make this
size 15
marker face color
equals and we'll do what green just
because there we go run very hard to
actually see what's going on there still
25 dots they kind of overlap as you can
see they print them over each other of
course if we really wanted to make it
look horrible we could just make that
really huge
generally though you want something a
little bit smaller and cuter we'll just
try doing it this way there we go that's
too small to even see the face so four
you can start to see the face on there
around four and maybe an eight eight
might be a good number for this there we
go eight again that all just depends on
what you're trying to show and display
so we've covered a lot of stuff here as
far as our lines we've covered
opaque with our alpha setting on there
give us some nice pastels you can see
how they overlap and how they cross over
we covered the line width different size
on there different formats for the line
itself and these are all you can combine
all these so you can have our line width
equals two line style equals dash you
can bring this down here also to the
markers and then we added markers in
just entered a circle a
plus sign the square a little tick which
uses a one
then we had a marker size and a marker
color face and we combine those you see
we get a nice different series of
representations we also briefly
mentioned color where you didn't have to
use like in here we used color black
someplace up here and have to find it we
use the actual number for the color as
opposed to i changed them to red and
blue so you can get very precise on the
color if you have a very specific color
set that you need to match your website
or whatever you're working on all those
are tools in the matplot library so we
have one more piece to formatting the
graph so we want to show you and then we
have two big sections we're going to go
over the different graphs that they have
along with a challenge problem so let's
go to the last section we're going to
look at is limits we're going to limit
our data so this first primer is going
to paste in there we're going to create
our subplots one two so one row two
columns we're gonna do a figure size of
ten comma five this should all look
familiar now since we've done a number
of them and we're gonna go ahead and
plot and this is an interesting notation
you should notice here our axis zero so
one we've used instead of you can just
iterate through them but they're just an
array so it's an array of zero is still
the axes of the first axes out of two
and we're going to plot x
x squared
x
x cubed line with 2. so we're going to
go ahead and just plot two graphs right
on top of each other without doing
multiple plots on here and we'll set the
grid equal to true one here let's go
ahead and run that and you can see here
our two plots with the x value going
across
and i'm going to do
something similar and by the way as you
can just if you look at it you can see
the grid on there that's all that is
easier to spot the data going across
we're gonna take the same
data for axes one so we have our plot of
x x squared x and x cubed line with two
and this time we're going to take our
axis one and do y limit
it's actually set underscore y limit
this is the y-axis so it's going to be
an array of two two values and we'll do
0 comma 60 i'm just making these numbers
up the guys in the back actually made
them up i'm just using their numbers and
we're going to set the x limit
and we'll set the x limit as
don't forget our brackets there
two comma five
so it's the same data going in and but
we're setting a limit on it let's go
ahead and run that and let's see what it
comes out of and here we have the y
limit 0 to 60 so we're looking at just
the lower part of this curve here up to
here and we have the x limit 2 to 5. so
that starts right here at 2 and you can
see very different graphs this is kind
of nice because you could actually put
one of these on top of the other if you
wanted to draw focus to one part of a
graph remember how we did that earlier
one inside the other but just a quick
note you can easily limit your graph and
re-kind of reshape the way it looks
quite easily and we can also add that
grid down there if we want a grid
we'll run that and add the grid in there
oops i guess you have to do the grid
beforehand
switch that there we go sometimes the
order on this is really important so you
may double check your order when you're
printing these things out it also helps
if i change it to one so in this case
might not be the order i wonder if i'll
go back here as one there we go so
doesn't matter the order and grid but
you can set the grid for easy viewing
here nice setup on there but you can see
how we can limit the data
so let's start looking at some other 2d
graphs and make this cell a markdown so
we run it as a nice pretty title to it
and let's go ahead and create some data
with an np array we'll do
0 to 5 on here there we go and let's
look at four common
graphs we'll put them side by side so
we'll do a figure our axes equals plot
subplots one four columns and then
figure size hopefully it'll fit nicely
on here it seems to do a pretty good on
here and i'll go and just run that since
we're in there run you'll see i have my
four blank plots on here
and we'll start with axes of zero let's
set title
and we want this to be a scatter plot
a scatter plot just means it has a bunch
of dots on it so here's our axes of
zero dot scatter easy to remember
scatter a bunch of plots on there we'll
do our
n or we can do x or n there we go and
let's go ahead and do axes set title
scatter i've already did that we're just
going to do scatter
that's how you do it on there notice how
you create a scatter plot with simply
with the scatter control and we'll do
let's do the variable x
x
plus let's throw some randomness in here
usually scatter plots are have a lot of
random numbers connected to them that's
why they do them on there and so the
bigger the x gets the bigger the
randomness so 0.25 times the randomness
and what we should end up doing here is
with the scatter plot and you can see as
you go up it just kind of has some
random numbers and moves up and down the
line
but plus just the points so if you
remember from back up here where we did
marker
this is plotting basically just the
marker so it's a scatter plot
probably less used is a step plot so for
x is one we'll go ahead and do a step
plot so you can see what that looks like
and this time we'll use our n value
instead of x we generated that n value
up here and so for this we have n
n times 2 our n squared n times two n
squared line width equals two and if we
run that it creates a nice step up
let's see so we've got a scatter plot
we've got a steps
plot let's do a bar plot
and we'll use the same formula in n
squared alignment centered because you
can have them left or right with 0.5 and
alpha if you remember correctly that's
how opaque it is
let's see what that looks like on there
so we have some nice you can see here a
nice bar plot it should look very
similar to the step plot but colored in
and we can change the width let's see
what happens we do 0.9 run and if we
take width out completely
run that you can see it starts coming
together on there and we can change the
alpha we can take the alpha out too and
run that so now you have the solid
colors and if we take out the center
and run that
everything you really can't see the
shift on here because that's actually
the default on this but these are common
settings for the bar graph let me just
put them back in there there we go
alignment center and alpha now i can't
say i've used the step craft very much
there's certain other certain i guess
domains of expertise require a step
graph but the scatter plot and the bar
graph very common especially the bar
graph and we'll look at histograms here
in just a minute so i use histograms a
lot especially in data science but this
is nice if you have very concrete
objects somebody how many people are
wearing yellow hats
that kind of thing but if we're going to
do that let's go ahead and do the last
one which i see a lot more in the
sciences certainly using the data
science but more like for mapping i saw
publication on solar flares and they
were discussing the energy and so
filling in the graph gives it a very
different look so we're going to do the
fill between
and it's just like you think it'd be
it's fill between but with a underscore
between them and we'll do x and x
squared and x and x cubed and we'll do
color green and alpha again in case you
had other data you want to plot on there
you can see it forms a nice squared
coming up here and also if you look at
the bottom one is your squared value the
upper line is your cubed value and then
it fills in everything in between
if you remember from calculus this would
be if you had like a car a motor an
efficiency they would talk about the
efficiency going up and the loss and
you're looking for the space or the area
between the two lines so it gives you a
nice visual of that now let's look at a
few more basic two dimensionals so we
have our figure figure size on here
we're going to do a radar chart to be
honest i've never used a radar chart in
business or in data science i get to
find a reason to use one now so the
first line for doing a radar chart we
have to add axes into the figure and
with this this actually creates our oh
this let's run it so you can see what it
creates it creates a nice looks like
you're on a submarine and you're
tracking the hunt for red october or
something like that and it needs all of
these the polar is the fact that we're
doing polar coordinates
0 0.6.6 has to do with the size if you
take out any of these things and run
them you get just a box
if you take out the other half you
pretty much get nothing in there and if
you change these numbers and change them
a little bit you can see it gets bigger
they had 0.6 on here i'll go ahead and
leave it as one that's just kind of fun
that's all about the size on here the
height and the width and then let's
create some data t equals np line space
and this is 0 to 2 times np times pi so
if you remember that is the
distance across and we're going to
generate 100 points
so this is just the thing of data we're
putting together then we simply do an ax
dot plot and in this case let's do t
comma t which would be a diagonal line
on a regular chart and we'll give it a
nice color equals blue
and line width equals three let's see
what that looks like and we can see here
a spiral coming out remember this would
be just a diagonal line on a regular
chart what happens if we take this and
instead of t
times 0.5 there we go
and you can see it slightly alters the
way it spirals out we could do t times
two spirals that a little quicker so
it's kind of just a fun i've like i said
i've never used a
radar chart it's a column but you can
always think of radar submarine kind of
looks like one of those or in an
airplane
and none of this would be complete if we
didn't discuss histograms oh my gosh do
i use a histogram so much and we'll use
our numpy that we have set as np to
generate oh looks like we have a hundred
thousand variables we're going to set
equal to n and of course we create our
figure and our axes from subplots 1 2
figure size 12 14 so we're going to look
at two different variations of the
histogram and we'll set a title default
histogram set our title there and then
this is simply
hist for histogram and we'll just go
ahead and put in our n in there and let
me run this and see what that looks like
and let's talk about what is going on
here
so we generated an array here of data
1000 random arrays it looks like they're
mostly between minus four and four
and then it adds up each one it says
zero you have thirty five thousand that
are zero so that's what's most common on
here and we have twenty thousand that
are somewhere in this range right here
between the minus 2 and well it looks
like 1 and minus 2. and somewhere
between 0 and 1 there's 30 000 numbers
so all this is saying is this is how
common these variables are and this
gives you this point in so many
directions when you're looking at data
science to go ahead and run your
histogram so you should always have your
histogram and you can always put limits
and all the other different things on
your array just like you did on the
other graphs on there and then we're
going to do a cumulative detailed
histogram
and all it is is a histogram let me just
do that
and we set cumulative equal to true
and bins equal 50. and i really want to
highlight the the cumulative equals true
is important but we can now choose how
many bins we have in the first one it
kind of selected them for us in this
case let me go ahead and run this and
you'll see it has a prints of data out
for us and here's our whoops
must have missed oh there we go doesn't
help that i put it over the old one
there we go okay
so now you have your default histogram
and then we have a cumulative histogram
and we should have 50 steps in there and
let's just find out if that's true not
so much by counting them i'm not going
to count them if you want to you can
count them let's just change it to 10
and see what happens and we see here we
have now 10 counts of that
and we could set that for 5
and run that
and then we have our five on there and
we go ahead and take the cumulative
equals true out just so you can see what
that looks like and let me run that on
here too
that looks just like it did before i
think there's what one two three four
five six seven eight they have eight
different bins on here is what the
default came out of
put that back in there run
and so now it should look almost
identical and it does and then we can
put the cumulative back in see what that
looks like with the cumulative
and run that
and we can see how that shifts
everything over and has a slightly
different luck
wait it shifts it all to the right no it
doesn't actually shift it to the right
it's cumulative so it's the total of the
different occurrences and so what that
means is like if you consider this like
for the year of rainfall we have like
day one you had a little bit of rain day
two we have more rain and so if you look
at the number this is a hundred thousand
thirty five thousand so it's
accumulative detail the histogram of the
currents as it grows and rainfall is a
good one because that would be a
cumulative histogram of how much rain
occurred throughout the year and we're
going to look at two more graphs we've
already looked at a bunch of them we
looked at our radar graph we've looked
at scatter step bar fill in
basic plots we've looked at different
ways of showing the data you know we can
increase the size of the line the look
the color the alpha setting
so let's look at contour maps just put
that in there there we go draw a contour
map and before we draw a contour map
we need to go ahead and create data for
it and if you have contours your data is
all going to have three different values
so let's go ahead and create the data
here we have our you'd import your
matplot library your numpy so we have
our numbers array
and we'll import matplot.cm
and that's your color maps so you have
all these different color maps you can
look at there's like hundreds of color
maps so if you don't want to do your own
color you can even do your own color map
they're pretty diverse and of course our
plt we're going to our pi plot and to
generate our different data we're going
to create a delta
0.025 and we'll start with x when we're
going to create an array between -3 and
3 and delta increments of 0.025
and we'll have our y we'll do something
similar and then we'll create our x y
into a mesh grid again these are all
numpy commands so if you're not familiar
with these you'll want to go back and
review our numpy tutorial and we'll do
an exponential on here minus x squared
minus y squared for z1 we'll do a z2 so
we have two different areas and z equals
z of 1 minus z2 times 2.
so we've created a number of values here
and let me go ahead and run this and
let's plug that in so you can see where
those values are going so once we've set
these we're going to create our figure
and our x from our plt subplots we're
going to create the variable cs and this
is going to be our contour so right here
cs is our contour surface and we're
feeding it x y and z if you remember x y
we created as our x and y components
using our mesh grid and you know what
let's do this just because it's kind of
good to see this let's go ahead and
print
x
and let's print
y and i always like to do this when i'm
working with something that's either is
really complicated in this case is what
we're looking at or you don't understand
yet so we've created a mesh grid we have
x y and when we're done with this we end
up with here's our x
and this set of values and our y so
these are x and y coordinates and then
we've also created z based on our x and
y so we have x capital x capital y and
capital z is our three components x and
y be in the coordinates well z is going
to be our actual height since we're
doing a contour map so we created our
contour map from our x y and z
coordinates we want to go ahead and put
in a c label maybe we want to go ahead
and do a title on here
we'll put that in our set title and this
is a
contour there we go contour map
and let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like
and you'll see we generated a nice
little contour map there's different
settings you can play with on this but
you can picture this being you're on a
mountain climb and here we have a line
that's represents zero maybe at sea
level and then moving on up you have
your contours of 0.5 and then minus one
and different setups little hills i
guess if it's minus that's like a pit so
i guess you're going down into a pit at
minus five and minus one when on the
other side you can see you're going up
in levels so here's a mountaintop and
here's like a basin of some kind and in
data science this could represent a lot
of things this could also be
representing two different values and
maybe profits and loss i don't know if
i'd ever really do that as a contour map
but i'm sure you can be creative and
find something fun to do with a contour
map and then we're going to look at one
last map which is the 3d map and those
are can be really important as a final
product because they can show so much
additional information that you can't
fit on two-dimensional graphs
there we go draw a 3d image
and so we're going to import from our
mpl toolkits the implant 3d and the axis
3d we're going to import axis 3d this is
what's going to let us work with the 3d
image and this should look familiar
we're going to create another figure
just like we did before figure size 14
by 6 it's a good fit on the screen we'll
go ahead and run that
so we have our figure and let's go ahead
and take our x and we're going to set
that equal to fig dot add subplot that
should also be familiar from earlier and
we're going to work with this sets the
settings for the projection we're going
to use one two one projection 3d and
we'll see what that looks like in just a
minute and we just created some
three-dimensional data here before
where we had x y and z capital x y and z
so we're going to reuse that data we're
just going to use that since this also
this is also a three-dimensional image
so let's use that for a
three-dimensional graph and we simply do
ax plot underscore
surface
and our capital x
capital y capital z so there's our data
coming in and we're going to add some
settings in here we're going to do r
stride 4 c stride 4 and line with 0.
i'll show you what that is here in just
a minute let's go ahead and run that so
we can see our graph
and of course it helps if i don't add an
extra comma in there and you can see it
generates this really beautiful
three-dimensional graph
so let's take a little bit time to
explore some of these numbers we have
going in here
we have the r stride 4 the c stride 4
and the projection 3d projection 3d is
the important one because that's telling
us that this is a 3d graph here
so what are these first numbers one two
one let's just change one of these i'm
going to change this to five
and it's going to give me an error let's
change it to one
and that didn't work let's change this
middle one to three instead
and you're going to see how it starts
reshaping the size and how it fits on
the screen
and we'll change the first one to two
we'll run that one
and again it's changed the dimensions
and the size and how it fits on here
play with these numbers to get a nice
look and feel for it part of it is the
tilt and the angle
i'll do seven on this one
there we go you can see it really
shifted it there
but again that changes the size now fits
on the canvas
but we'll leave it at the one
two
and just so you get a good look at what
we're talking about here this is column
width and index from before
if we do one one one you can see that it
now spreads it out all the way across
uses the whole set up on there so this
has to do with the size and how big you
want it to be now there's one term that
we didn't cover in this yet but we've
used it throughout the whole setup
and i'm just going to type that down
here even though we're not going to go
into detail and that's the term heat
map you might see that it's kind of
starting to lose ground as far as a
common reference but there sure are a
lot of people who still talk about heat
maps what is a heat map well it is
simply a color map that's all it is so
if you ever see the term heat map
that refers to the fact this is in
different colors representing different
heights
that one is in the heat map but you can
see up here we switched into
let me go back up here here we go this
one has different colors for the
different values
a lot of times you'll use like instead
of x and y you might do a heat map
where you have a fourth value and the
fourth value represents the color and so
you'll see this 3d image in a nice
colors represented by heat map that's
all it is so if you see the term heat
map that only means we're plotting some
of the data in color to make it stand
out or to give it a fourth dimension in
this case
so we've covered a lot of things on map
plot and that brings us cover all the
basics so that brings us to practice
example and this is going to be the
challenge for you and let me go ahead
and change our cell
cell type mark down and run that so it
looks pretty
practice example write a python program
to create a pie chart of the popularity
of programming languages okay excellent
and if you're going to have a challenge
we need some data and i'll just throw in
our import our map library at the
beginning you should do that
automatically and so for our data to
plot we're going to have our languages
we're going to have python we're going
to have java php javascript c-sharp c
plus so those are six categories and
then we have our popularity oops
misspelling there popularity we'll give
the first one 22.2 percent java 17.6 and
i don't know if these are real numbers
they pulled
my guess is that they might have just
been made up because i don't know if
python's really that much more popular
than the other ones maybe specific to
data science because python is very
popular in data science right now
because it has so many options the only
other program that's highly used and
exclusively for data science is r so
python's big and python also does a lot
more it's a full programming language
where r is primarily for data science
they didn't put r in here so we have
python we have java we have our php and
you can see the different values they've
given it or different percentages
and i did add these up does not add up
to 100 it adds up to 71 percent or
something like that
and then we're going to give colors and
we've chosen these guys in the back
brought in these colors i'm not sure
what these colors are we'll find out in
a minute so i'll be exciting but you can
see they're using the actual color
values you can pull off of a color wheel
or something like that you could have
just as easily done blue red green if
you're too lazy to pick the exact colors
and then let's go ahead and solve this
and see we got here we're going to do
something a little fancy just because we
can the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to use a variable called
explode and you'll notice that there's
six variables in here so that matches
our six different categories and the
first one we've done is point one and
then zero zero zero zero zero point one
when we put this in here under the
explode in the plot it will actually
push that square out so it's a really
cool feature to highlight certain
information on a pie chart
and this is simply
plt dot pi and we're plotting
popularity there we go and before we add
in all the really cool settings for this
let's go ahead and run it and you'll see
we generate a nice flat pie
not too exciting there and then we'll go
ahead and put in all the extras i talked
about explode we can explode one of the
values out so here's our explode equals
explode labels as languages because we
want to know what the different colors
mean here's our colors equals colors our
auto picture and this is standard print
format so that's a python setup on there
and that's just going to put the value
on the pie slice and then we're going to
add shadow because it just looks cooler
with a shadow gives a little 3d look and
we'll do a start angle of 140. let's go
ahead and run this and take a look and
see what comes out of that
and look how that changes the whole
setup so here's our labels there's our
value we put on there there's our slices
pushed out there's our shadow with 3d
effect
and then we started at 140. we could
also rotate this let's just do this
angle
90
and if we run it
you'll see the blue pie slice has moved
up a little bit we could actually do
actually let's just take the whole
starting triangle out and run he'll
default to zero
this is what it looks like if it
defaulted to zero so depending on where
you want the highlighted slice to appear
usually you want that appear on the left
because people read left to right and so
it draws a focus onto in this case
python and how great python is i'm a
little biased we're teaching a python
tutorial so it should be understandable
that we're looking at python and one
last reference before we close you can
go over to the map plot library dot pi
plot set up and if you go underneath
there the different functions on there
you can look this up on their website
you'll see a full list and this is why
it's so important to go through a
tutorial like this because this list is
just so massive trying to figure out
like here's our bar plot there's a bar h
you can add barbs there's a box plot we
didn't cover
c labels a totally different kind of for
your contour plot you can set up in
there if you go down here we have our
figures we used on there we showed you
the basics how to do the figure you'll
see some
closer references on those
there's a histogram down here i s t
there's also the his 2d makes a 2d
histogram plot h lines all of this these
are all the different commands that are
underneath of here and you can see it's
pretty extensive
we've covered all the basic ones so that
you know have a solid ground to look at
these different options so when you come
to these functions some of them are
going to look a little off or not off
will look unfamiliar but you'll still
have the availability to probably
understand most of this and have a basic
understanding of your matplot library we
will learn how to visualize data and
draw insights with different charts and
graphs using the c bond library
these visualizations are often referred
to as plots in python
so what is c bond in python the c-bond
library in python is a widely popular
data visualization library that is
commonly used for data science and
machine learning tasks
it is built on top of the matplotlib
data visualization library
and allows you to perform exploratory
data analysis using cbon you can create
interactive plots to answer specific
questions about your data
it helps you find trends in your data
that you can't notice just by looking at
the data
now to understand the siebond library in
detail and how to create different plots
and know the data better we'll be using
two data sets in our demo
the first one is the empty cache data
set and the second is the popular iris
flower data set
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and start with our
demonstration
so i am on my jupyter notebook let me go
ahead and
rename the notebook i'll say
cbon
demo
we'll rename it
all right
you can see i have
the first two cells already filled in
so while working on an exploratory data
analysis project using python you will
need numpy pandas matplotlib and c-bond
libraries for data manipulation and
visualization
so let's import these libraries first so
i've already written input numpy as np
pandas pd matplotlib.pi plot splt c-bond
sns all right so i'll hit shift enter to
run this
first cell
all right
now using the read underscore csv
function that is present in the
pandas library i'm importing my data set
that is empty cars i'll tell you what
empty cars is about this is a csv data
set and here i have given the location
where my data set is present
let's run it
all right
now
let me go ahead and print the first
five rows
of my empty cars
data frame
for that i am using the head function if
i run it
okay you can see here
it has given me the first five rows the
index starts from zero till four so
total five rows of information
and
you can see these are the
columns that are present
in the empty cast data set the first is
the
model of the car
now just let me give you a background
about this data set
so the data is taken from the 1974
motor trend us magazine
it has information about fuel
consumption and 11 different aspects of
automobile design and performance of 32
cars
all right
so here we have the first column as the
model of the car and then we have mpg
which is
miles per
gallon
then we have
cyl which stands for the number of
cylinders in the vehicle or the car
then we have disp which is displacement
in
cubic inches so these all values are in
cubic inches
after that we have hp which is cross
horsepower
then we have something called as
dr80 which is basically the rear axle
ratio
then we have wt which is the
weight of the
car in pounds
so think of it as
weight multiplied by 1000 pounds
all right and then we have cusec which
is 1 4 mile time this is a measure for
acceleration
then we have something called as vs this
is
the type of
engine for each of the vehicles so zero
stands for
v-shaped engine and one stands for
straight engine
then we have am which is basically
the mode of transmission so
zero is for automatic transmission and
one is for manual transmission
then we have the number of
forward gears present in the vehicle and
then we have something called as carb or
carb
this stands for the number of
carburetors so carburetors is a device
for supplying a spark ignition engine
with a mixture of fuel and air
all right
now
we'll use the info function to print the
summary of the data frame so the info
function returns information regarding
the index
data type column data types then we
have the information about normal values
and memory usage so i'll write my data
frame name which is empty cars
dot i'm going to use the info function
let's run it
and here you can see we have
all the columns
there are total 32
entries from 0 to 31 so
data about 32
cars
then here you can see the date types
and the memory usage
now moving ahead
let me
just print the
shape of the data frame that will give
you the number of rows and columns
present
i'll use the shape attribute
you can see here there are total
32 rows and 12 columns in my data set
now the c bond library provides a range
of plotting functions that makes the
visualization and analysis of data
easier
so we will cover some of the crucial
plots that are available in c-bond
so let's start with a bar plot
i'll give a
comment as
bar plot
now
first understand what a bar plot is so a
bar plot gives an estimate of the
central tendency of a numeric variable
with the height of each rectangle
it provides some indication of the
uncertainty around the estimate using
error bars now to build this plot you
usually choose a categorical column in
the x-axis and a numeric column on the
y-axis
so
we'll create a bar plot between the
number of cylinders and the miles per
gallon
so let's start
i'll
declare a variable called res which
essentially stands for result
then i'll use sns
which is for the cbon library
say sns dot
followed by my bar plot function
and inside the function
i'll pass in my
data frame name that is empty cars
and then
for x axis within the bracket using
quotation i will give my column name
as cylinder so this is going to be my x
axis
and for y-axis i'll say
my data frame name empty cars
then the square bracket followed by my
y-axis column that is miles per gallon
now to display i'm going to use the
matplotlib function i'll say plt dot
show
let's run it and we'll see the result
there you go
so here you can see on the
x-axis we have the number of cylinders
so in our data we have
vehicles with
four six or eight cylinders
and on the y-axis you can see the miles
per gallon
now what essentially this graph tells us
is that
when the number of cylinders in the
vehicle increases my miles per gallon on
mpg for the vehicles decreases
and you can see these
black lines
so these lines indicate
the uncertainty around
the estimate using error bars
all right
now you can create the
same bar plot using another way now we
will exclusively define the x and y axis
columns and also pass the name of the
data frame using the
data argument
let me show you how to do it
i'll use the same variable name res
which stands for result i'll say sns dot
bar plot
now inside the
bar plot function
i am going to exclusively define my x
axis i'll say x equal to
i'll pass in my column as
cylinder
then i'll say y-axis
which is miles per gallon
and then using the data attribute
i'll pass in my data frame name that is
empty cars
and finally we'll write plt dot show
let me run it
you see here we have the exact
same bar plot
as the above one so this is another way
to create a bar plot now python c bond
allows the users to assign colors to the
bars
so the bar chart that we are going to
create will convert all the bars to a
particular color
so for that i am going to use the color
argument
so i will say res
equal to
sns dot my function that is bar plot
i'll say x
equal to
cylinder
my y axis
will have
mpg
and then i'll say data
is empty cars
give a comma and my final attribute i'll
say
color
equal to i'll say yellow
close the bracket
and then
i'm going to write plt dot show
if i run it you can see here
all the bars have been converted to
yellow color now
you can change the
color
argument let's say i'll make it to red
if i print it you can see here all the
bars have been changed to red color now
all right now cbone library also has the
palette argument
which you can use to give different
colors to the bars
so if you go to
google and search for
seaborn palette
you have a nice link here
so here you have there are different
pallets provided by
c bond you can see here sns dot color
palette
and these are the
names of the palette
you can use whichever palette you want
all right
so
i'll say res
equal to
sns dot
bar plot
we'll use our
first method of
assigning
a bar plot so i'm using my data frame
empty cars and this time we are going to
change the x and y labels let's say i'm
using
my x label as
transmission whether automatic or manual
transmission
and then in my y-axis i'll have
miles per gallon
then
i'm going to say
palette
equal to
i made a spelling mistake here
let's say our palette is
set to this is the name of the palette
i'll write plt dot show
if i run it you can see here
we have the
two modes of transmission zero is for
automatic transmission of the vehicle
one is for manual transmission
and you can see the miles per gallon for
each of the modes of transmission
if you want you can change the pallet
colors let me just copy this
i'll paste it in my new cell and instead
of set to let's see we'll
use
another palette
called as rocket
and i'm also going to alter
my x and y labels let's say in my x
label i'll have
gear
and my y label will be horsepower
if i run it
you see here we now have a different
palette and the bars are of different
colors
on the x axis you have the gears
three gear four gear or five gear
vehicle
and on the
y-axis you have the horsepower
so from the graph you can see
the horsepower is low for vehicles that
have four gears
while it is high
for the vehicles that have five gears
now let's understand how to create a
count plot
so the count plot function in the python
c-bond library returns the count of
total values for each category using
bars
we will create a count plot that returns
the total number of vehicles for each
category of cylinders
i'll just give a comment here as
count plot
all right
so i'll start
sns dot
i'll use the count plot function
and i'll define my x axis as
cylinders
my y axis
won't have any label or any column
because y-axis will only show the
count
then i'm going to
use my
data parameter or the argument and pass
in my data frame name that is empty cars
let's say i'll set the
palette
to
set one
me run it
okay there is some error let's
debug the error
says str
object has no attribute get
okay so this should be
without the single quotes
make sure the data frame name is without
the
single quotes let's run it again
there you go
so you can see here this is a nice count
plot that
shows the number of cylinders on the
x-axis and on the y-axis you have the
count you can see here
there are more number of vehicles that
have eight cylinders and there are
less number of vehicles or cars that
have six cylinders
and actually you can count it as well so
you can see here there are 14 cars that
have eight cylinders there are
11 cars that have four cylinders and
there are seven cars that have
six cylinders
all right
now moving ahead
the next count plot will show the number
of cars for each
carburetor so for that i am going to say
sns dot
count plot
my x axis will now have
the variable
carburetor
i'll see data equal to empty cars
and
my pallet
i'll set it to
set one
let's say set two now let me run it
you can see it here
on the x-axis we have the different
number of carburetors one two three four
six and eight
and you can see we have more number of
cars that have two and four carburetors
and there are very few vehicles that
have
six and eight carburetor
cool now moving ahead
so the python c-bond library allows you
to create horizontal count plots where
the feature column is on the y-axis and
the count is on the x-axis let me show
you how to create a horizontal count
plot
i'll say sns dot
count plot
i'm going to define my
y label or the y axis as
gear
i'll say data equal to
empty cars
and
set my
pallet to
let's say rocket
let me run it okay you see here this is
a
horizontal count plot if you compare it
with the above one these were all
vertical
count plot as in the bars were
vertically aligned but here you can see
the bars are all horizontally aligned
and
on the y-axis you have the gear column
and on the x-axis you have the count
so if you mark here properly you can see
there are 15 vehicles with three gears
there are
12 vehicles that have four gears and
there are total five vehicles with five
gear
now you can also create a grouped count
plot using the hue parameter
so the hue parameter accepts the column
name for
color encoding
now let's
build
a count plot that shows the number of
cars for each category of gears grouped
by
the number of cylinders
so we are going to group based on the
number of cylinders let me show you how
to use the hue parameter for that
i'll say
sns.count plot
in the x axis i'll have my
gear column
then i am going to pass my hue parameter
that will have the
cylinder column or the number of
cylinders for each vehicle
i'll pass my data frame
using the data argument
as empty cars
and say pallet
i'll set my pallet to set one
let's run it
if i scroll down you see here we have a
count plot
on the x axis you have three four and
five gears of the different vehicles
and
for each gear you have the bars
that represent the number of cylinders
so for vehicles that have three gears we
have
majority of the vehicles having eight
cylinders
similarly for vehicles that have four
gears we have most of the vehicles with
four cylinders
and if you compare for the
cars that have five
gears
so we have equal number of vehicles that
have
four and eight cylinders and then
we have
one vehicle that has
six cylinders
cool now moving ahead
so the c-bond library supports the
dist plot function that creates the
distribution of any continuous data
let's create the distribution of miles
per gallon of the different vehicles or
the cars
the mpg matrix measures the total
distance the car can travel per gallon
of fuel so here i'll give
a comment as dist plot which stands for
distribution plot
i'll say sns dot
dist plot
i'll pass in my
data frame name that is empty cars
give a period and say
mpg which is my column name
then i'm going to
define the number of bins that i want
let's say 10
and then i'll use the
color argument
and i'll say let's say g which is for
green
let's run it now
there you go
if i scroll down you can see we have a
nice
distribution plot
so these are all histograms and
you can see we have a smooth curve
and this shows the distribution of
miles per gallon that is present in our
data set all right
now moving ahead
you can also create heat maps using the
cbon library
so the heat maps will
let you visualize matrix like data
the values of the variables are
contained in a matrix and are
represented as colors
you can create a correlation heat map
which is a graphical representation of a
correlation matrix representing the
correlation between different variables
so in our example we will create a heat
map where you can find the correlation
between each variable in the empty cars
data set
just give a comment as heat map
i'll say sns
and
i'll use the heat map function
i'll pass in my data frame name that is
empty cars followed by
my function called
c o r r which is for correlation
then i'll say c bar
is equal to true so the
c bar argument is used to draw the color
bar
then i'll say
line bits
i'll
pass it as 0.5
let's run it
there you go
here you can see we have a nice heat map
and on the right side you can see the
color bar that starts from
minus point eight and goes up to plus
point eight so this ranges between
minus one and plus one
and
the bars or the
cube you can see that have
a lighter color
have a positive correlation
and the ones that are
dark have a negative correlation
so for example
you can see here
for cylinder and mpg
the color is really dark which is around
this region minus 0.8 this means
when the number of cylinders in the car
increases your miles per gallon
decreases
and this
we also
had seen in our first
bar plot this one
you can see here whenever
the number of
cylinders increased your miles per
gallon had decreased
and this is what
has been depicted
in our correlation map or the heat map
but if you see for
cylinder and displacement there is a
positive correlation
which comes around this
color bar range
similarly there are other features in
the data set for example if you compare
for the weight of the vehicle and
the number of cylinders
there is a positive correlation which
means when the
weight of the vehicle increases the
number of cylinders present in the
vehicle also increases
and the others you can also compare and
find out the correlation based on this
color bar choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1000 plus hours
of video content for free visit scale up
by simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
okay now let's move ahead
the c bond scatter plot function helps
you create plots that can draw
relationships between two continuous
variables so to understand about scatter
plots and other plotting functions
henceforth we are going to use
iris flat data set so let's go ahead and
load the iris flat data set i'll say
irish equal to say sns dot
load underscore
data set
so this iris floor data set is already
inbuilt into the sns or the c bond
library
now we'll go ahead and
print the first five rows
from the data set
there you go
here you can see here
there are total
four feature variables you have the
sample length
supple width better length and petal
width of the
three species of flower
that is satosa
virginica and versicolor
so using this data set we are going to
see the rest of the c bond plotting
functions first let me go ahead and
print the different species of flower
and the
count for each of the species of flowers
that we have in our data set i'll say
irish
within square brackets i'll pass in the
output or the target variable that is
species and i'll use the function that
is
value
underscore counts
let's run it
there you go so we have
50 flaws of satosa type
again 50 flaws of
versicolor species and then
we have another 50 flowers of type
virginica so there are total 150 flowers
present in our data set
all right
i will create a scatter plot to show the
relationship between sepal length and
petal length for different species of
iris flares
so i'll say sns
dot
followed by the
scatter plot function in the x axis i
will say
sepal length
column
give a comma
i'll pass in my
y-axis with
petal length
then i'll say
data
equal to
iris
now let's run it
you can see here
this is my
scatter plot between
sepal length and petal length
now
you can classify the different species
of flowers using the hue parameter as
species in the function
so what i'll do is
i'm going to copy my
above
code i just paste it here
and we are going to edit in this cell
itself
i'll add a last parameter called hue
and this will have my species column
let's run it and see the difference
there you go
here you can see
we have a nice scatter plot
the
blue dots are for satosa
the orange dots are for
versicolor and for virginica you have
the green dots
from this scatter plot you can see that
for virginica flowers the supple length
and the petal length are higher than
your versicolor and
satosa
and this region is completely
procetus of loss
so you can see that the satosa flowers
have
lower sample length and petal length
all right
you can also
use another
parameter known as the size
that will
differentiate
the different pieces of flower in terms
of the size of the dots
i'll say size as species
let's run it you can see the result
there you go
so here you can see the
virginica
flowers are in green dots
the size is small
followed by versicolor with medium sized
dots and then
we have satosa
whose size is
large
okay
now the python c-bond library lets you
visualize data using pair plots that
produces a matrix of relationship
between each variable in the data set
so let me show you how to create a peer
plot i'll say sns dot
pair plot which is the function
then i'll pass in my data frame name
that is iris
i'll put this
iris data frame within
double quotes
and will run it
okay there is some error here let's
debug the error
data must be panned as data frame okay
what i'll do is i'll just
remove
the double quotes and we'll run it
this might take some time to create the
pair plot so
just wait for a while
there you go here you can see we have a
nice pair plot
on the
y-axis you have the
supple length supple width petal length
and petal width similarly on the x-axis
also you have the
same
feature columns
all the diagonal plots are histograms
and the rest of the plots are
scatter plots
now you can convert the diagonal visuals
to
kde or kernel density estimation plots
and the rest of the scatter plots using
the hue parameter
this makes the pair plot easier to
classify each type of flower
so
i'll just copy this
cell of code
paste it here
and
i'll say hue
equal to
species
then
i'll say
palette
equal to
set one
let's run it and we'll
see the new pair plot now
this might take some time
there you go
so here you have the
bear plot ready
and on the
right side you can see the different
species the red color dots represent
satosa flowers
the blue color dots represent versi
color
and
the
green color
dots represent virginica flowers
now if you
look at this graph
you will find that
your petal length is the best feature to
classify the three different species of
flowers
with the reason being you can see here
they are very well
categorized and they are separated
all the red dots present here in the
petal length represent satosa flowers
around this range
all the
blue dots represent
versicolor flowers and the green dots
are all
virginica flowers
so out of the four features petal width
petal length sample width and
supple length
you can take
petal length as the
best feature to
differentiate between the three species
of flowers
all right
now
coming to
lm plot function
so the
lm plot function in the
c bond library draws a linear
relationship as determined through
regression for continuous variables
so let's create the plot to show the
relationship between petal length and
petal width of the different species of
iris flowers
i'll just give a comment here as
lm plot
i'll say sns dot
lm plot
in the x axis we'll have
petal length
give a comma
in the y-axis
i'll pass in
petal width
and i'll pass in my data frame using the
data argument or parameter which is iris
let's run it
you can see it here
we have a nice
plot
the line you see here
is a linear regression line
now in this
lm plot you can use the hue parameter to
differentiate between each species of
flask and you can set
markers for different
species let me show you how to do it
i'll say sns dot
lm plot
we'll say x
as our
petal length
give a comma
i'll write y
as
petal
width
then i'm going to pass the hue parameter
in here i'll say
my column as pcs
then i'll give data equal to
my data set name that is iris
and now you can pass in
markers argument
to differentiate the different
types of flaws
let's say i want to represent setosa
with
dot or o
then my next species which is
versicolor should be represented with a
star symbol
and the final
virginica species of flowers should be
represented with let's say
this arrow mark
now let me go ahead and run it
there you go
you have three different
linear regression lines
and
the circle dots in blue color represent
satosha
the orange color stars represent
versicolor flowers and
the triangles represent virginica
flowers so this is how you create
a linear relationship between the
different
types of flares using the regression
line
all right
now let's
take a look at the final plotting
function
where we will create a box plot
a box plot also known as a box and
whisker plot depicts the distribution of
quantitative data
the box represents the quartiles of the
data set
the whiskers so the rest of the
distribution except for the outliers
now let's see the distribution of the
three species of flowers
based on their sepal width
i just give a comment as box plot
is the final plot that we are going to
see in our c bond
demo
i'll say
sns.box plot
in the x axis we'll have the species
column
in the y axis we'll have
supple
width
then i'll pass my
data
as iris
let's run it
there you go
we have this
box plot created
at the bottom
in the x axis you can see we have
the box plot for
satosa flowers
orange for
versa color flowers and green for
virginica flowers
now this line represents
median which is inside the box
so this is also the median for
versicolor flowers you can compare the
median
sample width for each of the flowers
from the y axis
this line represents the
maximum
supple width value for satosa flower
and this line at the bottom represents
the minimum
length of the supple bit for satosa
flowers
now these dots that you see outside the
box plot are called as outliers
the extended lines that are outside the
box plot are known as whiskers
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on
cbon
library in python so first we
imported our empty cars data set
then we saw how to create a bar plot
we learned how to use the color argument
or the parameter inside
bar plot
we also
saw how to use the palette attribute or
the palette
parameter
then we learnt about
creating count plots
then we saw how to create horizontal
count plot
now moving ahead
we saw how to create
distribution plot
then we saw
correlation heat map
after that we analyzed the other
functions
such as the scatter plot
then we had the pair plot
and we had the
lm plot for
finding the linear relationship and
later we saw the
box plot using the iris flower data set
so first we will explain what exactly
the meaning of bokeh
is then we will take a look at scatter
charts and see how we can implement them
in bokeh
next we will understand what line charts
are the scenarios in which they are used
and how they can be coded in python
bokeh
then we'll move on to pie charts and
understand how data distribution can be
represented using them
next we will take a look at histograms
then we'll move on to bar plot and
understand the difference between
histograms and bar plots
we'll then take a look at area plot and
how to understand them
and then we will move on to the layout
function in bokeh which is used to make
interactive web pages
and finally we will use a data set to
understand how we can make interactive
charts in bokeh by using everything that
we've already learned in this video
so the first question that probably
comes to your mind is what exactly is
bokeh
bokeh is a python library which is used
to make highly interactive graphs and
visualizations
this is done in bokeh using html and
javascript
this makes bokeh a powerful tool for
creating projects custom charts and web
design based applications
now bokeh is a python library for
creating interactive visualizations for
modern web browsers
it helps you build beautiful graphics
ranging from simple plots to complex
dashboards with streaming data sets
with bokeh you can create javascript
power visualizations without writing any
javascript yourself
this makes it a very powerful tool for
data visualization
next let's take a look at scatter charts
and how you can plot them in bokeh
now scatter plots are a plot of each
individual data point in the data
two variables are plotted against one
another and each data point on the
x-axis has a corresponding individually
plotted value on the y-axis
as a result the plot looks like a bunch
of scattered points
these are some examples of scatter
charts
here each point on the chart corresponds
to a value on the x-axis and its
respective value on the y-axis
using scatter plots we can see how two
different variables correspond to each
other
now let's see how we can plot scatter
charts using bokeh
so the first thing that we're going to
be doing is importing all of the
necessary modules for our python project
the first module that we're going to
need is the pandas module which is used
to work on data frames
next we will also be importing the
pandas bokeh module which is used to
implement bokeh on panda's data frames
next we will import bokeh.io which we
will use to show the various graphs that
we are plotting
we will also import bokeh dot plotting
which will help us in plotting all of
the various graphs that we're going to
be looking at
we'll also import glob a module which
will help us
merge our files and get them in the
required format
so the first line of code that we're
going to be writing is pandas underscore
bokeh dot output underscore notebook
this is basically just a line of code
which will help you see your output in
the same notebook itself
now let's see how we can plot scatter
plots in bokeh
we already have imported the figure
function from bokeh.plotting
the figure function contains most of the
plots that we want to plot such as line
plots scatter plots bar charts etc so
this is what we're gonna be using
the first thing that you're gonna need
to do is create a figure
so how do we do that
let's create a random variable p and
this we're gonna be initializing to the
figure function
now within this figure function we're
just going to add a couple of
parameters for our figure itself so
let's say we want the plot width
to be equal to 400
and the plot
height to be equal to 402 we're going to
be plotting a scatter plot in the form
of a square here next we know that a
scatter plot is nothing but various
circles which are plotted on top of our
graph
so that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna be plotting
circles
at certain coordinates
which are going to be given by our lists
so the first coordinate is going to be
the x-axis and the next list that you're
passing in is going to represent the
y-axis coordinates so over here let's
just plot
this as one comma two
three
four and five
and over here let's start with four
seven
these are just random points this is
just to show you how exactly you can
plot a graph in bouquet
and now let's just say that we want the
size of the circles to be equal to 10
and the color of every circle
to be
navy we're also going to give a random
parameter called alpha and equate that
to 0.5 this will just act as a
placeholder
now over here you've initialized your
figure function and given it certain
parameters
and using this figure function you're
calling the circle attribute of it
passing in other
parameters such as the x-axis
coordinates and the y-axis coordinates
the size of the circle the color of each
circle and
a random parameter called alpha so now
we've imported all of our modules
and this is how you plot a scatter chart
in bokeh
the same thing can be done when you look
at the line plot
all you have to do is initialize your
figure function
and call the line attribute of it pass
in your x-axis coordinates in your
y-axis coordinates
maybe pass in a couple of other
parameters that are required such as the
width that you want the line to be and
the color that you want the line to be
and finally all you have to do is show
the plot this is a basic overview of how
you can use bokeh to plot graphs
and here we have a line plot
so the main difference between the
scatter plot here and the line plot here
is that the line plot has various
different
points which are connected to each other
with the help of a line
so again what exactly are line charts
a line chart is a chart that represents
data as a series of points which are
connected to each other with the help of
a line it is used to see trends in our
data and track the way data changes over
a period of time
so this is the same chart that we just
plotted using bokeh right now so as you
can see
so the parameters that you know were
passed in were 1 2 3 4 and 5 on the x
axis
and 3 1 2
6 and 5 on the y axis
so how exactly the line chart is plotted
is that you plot each of these points
and then you connect them or join them
using a line
next let's take a look at pie charts and
how they can be implemented in bokeh
but first what exactly is a pie chart
a pie chart is a circular chart which is
divided into slices to represent how
much of the data belongs to a certain
category
it is a quick and easy way to see the
categories in our data and the
percentage of the data set that they
represent
on the other hand you have another type
of chart called a donut chart
donut charts are like pie charts with a
hole in the center and in this hole you
can use it to represent extra data
or you can draw a pie chart within that
hole itself
so this is an example of a pie chart
using this you can easily get to know
the various categories that our data is
divided into and the percentage that
each of these categories contribute
towards our data
like over here we have a pie chart which
represents crewmates and imposters in a
game called among us
so using this we can just say that
around 75 percent
of our
data is crewmates and 25 of it is
imposters
on the other hand you have a donut chart
which is almost exactly the same as the
pie chart except the middle portion is
missing values
and in this middle portion you can do
other things such as plot a pie chart
or represent other data within it
so now let's see how we can plot our pi
plots using python bokeh
but first we need to import the data
that we're gonna be using to plot all of
this
so the data that we're gonna be looking
at is the among us data
among us as you might know is a game
that caused quite a frenzy in the past
two years
so the data that we're gonna be working
at is the among us data set that you can
find on kaggle
among us was the new craze for people
playing mobile games that suddenly
exploded in popularity and became a hit
video game during the pandemic
now among us is basically a multiplayer
game where 4 to 10 players are dropped
in an alien spaceship
each player has their own role of
imposter or crewmate
the task of the crewmate is to run
around the spaceship to complete various
tasks which are assigned to them and
also to not get killed by an imposter
players can be voted off the ship so
each game becomes one of survival
so let's load this data set and create
more features
so now we've imported our data set as
you can see our data set has over 2000
rows and 14 columns
the first column that i want to show you
is the user id column
the user id column tells us which user
the game data was collected from
now there are 14 columns the game
completed data tells us the date and
time of
game completion
the team tells us if the player is an
imposter or a crewmate
the outcome
tells us if the game was won or lost
so over here this is each game that a
certain user has played user id is used
to represent the user who has played the
game and as you can see we've collected
data from 29 different people
and the number of games that these 29
people totally have played is over two
thousand
the outcome tells us whether the
user has won or lost in this game the
task completed tells us how many tasks
was completed by this user in this game
all tasks completed tells us when the
user was able to finish their tasks
murder tells us if the user was murdered
and imposter kills
tells us the number of kills by the
imposter
so if the user was not an impostor we do
not have data on how many kills was
committed by the impostor during that
particular game that's why this column
has a lot of missing values
gamelan tells us
the total duration of the game and
ejected tells us if the player was
ejected or thrown off of the spaceship
by their fellow players
sabotage is fixed is basically
the imposter within the game can create
sabotages and it's the crewmates duty to
fix them
so this tells us the number of sabotages
which was fixed by this particular
crewmate
time to complete all tasks tells us the
duration taken by the crewmates to
complete all the tasks and the rank
change tells us the change in rank after
wins or losses of the game
the region
or the game code tells us the server and
the game code
now first let's just see how exactly the
data is distributed
so this tells us how many
uh counts each column has
so as you can see here most of them have
the same number of counts except rank
change which has a couple of missing
values
unique tells us how many unique values
exist
in each column
so obviously team there will be two
because there are only two possible
outcomes you can either be a crewmate or
you can either be an imposter outcome
also has only two unique values because
you either win a game or you lose a game
task completed has 12 different values
and this is because the
number of tasks which have been
completed probably range from 1 to 12.
alt has completed has three values which
is yes no and missing data and the same
goes for murdered you have yes no or
missing data
impostor kills tells us how many kills
the imposter has made
so in this case
uh the most skills that the person has
made is probably nine
uh game length there are 988 different
values and ejected again there are only
two values because you can either be
ejected or you can either stay in the
game
now the top value tells us the most
frequently occurring value and the
frequency tells us the frequencies of
all of the top values
now let's create a feature called minute
and extract data from game length
so we're going to be splitting the game
length column which is this column and
we're going to be converting it into
minutes
and then we're going to be
using that data and creating a separate
uh feature column called minutes
out of it
so let's do this
so these are the first top two values of
our minutes call of our new minutes
column
uh the zeroth value is seven because the
first
game length that you see here was of
seven minutes so all that we're doing is
that we're gonna be splitting this
value which is seven minutes four
seconds and we're gonna be keeping only
the first value which is out of the
minutes
the second minutes value is 16 minutes
and that corresponds to the second value
in our minutes feature
variable
now
let's take a look at the murdered column
the modded column has yes no yes no
values and missing data set and missing
values
so let's change those we're gonna be
replacing no values with not murdered
yes values with murdered and the simple
dash with missing
and we're gonna be doing this in place
which basically means that this is going
to make a change to our main data frame
so this is done let's take a look at a
data frame now
this is what our data frame looks like
we have a game's length column we have a
minutes column and we also have made
changes to our murdered column which is
represented here so now we don't have
any missing values or dashes in our
murdered column we have all of it
represented as categorical data
and this is one of the main columns that
we're going to be using to plot our pi
plots
so now let's see how we can plot a pie
chart
the first thing that we're going to be
doing is that we're going to be
getting the total value counts
in our team column here
so we're gonna be plotting a pie chart
with the help of this team column and
we're gonna be getting the value counts
of each unique
value in the team column
so let's
you can do this with the help of the
value counts function that pandas data
frames provides us with
announce that we have the value counts
of each unique value which is present in
our team column let's plot it in the
form of a pie chart
we're gonna be doing this with the help
of the plot bokeh function
and the type of chart that we want to
plot is a pie chart
let's give it the title
as
ratio of
imposters
versus
chromates
and let's run this now
and this is what your pie plot looks
like after you've plotted it
so now the same thing can be done to
plot a donut plot
the first thing that we want to see is
if there are more crewmates or imposters
murdered or not in the game
to do this we will add two more features
angle and color which are
going to be used in the chart so to
get angle we're going to be importing pi
from math
and we're going to be converting our
angle in the form of radians
and as for the color feature we're going
to be having three different shades of
blue
so this is basically what our
murder data frame looks like
uh so over here you have not murdered
the total value counts of which
is 894 and the angle that this gives us
is 2.522302
and this is the corresponding color the
same goes for murdered which is 867
values and we've converted that into an
angle in radians and given it its own
color and finally we also have missing
values
of which there are 466 the angle is
1.314756 and it has its own
corresponding color so this is a data
frame that we're going to be using to
plot our donor chart
so from bookkeep.transform we import
cumulative sum
and the cumulative sum is what we're
going to be using to find the start of
our angle or basically to find
or basically to find how much portion of
our donut chart is going to be occupied
by the angle so the donut chart can be
plotted using the angular wedge function
from figure
so the x-axis here is 0 and the y-axis
is 1. the inner radius is the radius
that you are going to be giving to the
inner smaller circle and that we've
given us 0.15
the outer radius is the radius of the
bigger outer circle
and the direction in which our data is
going to be plotted is in the
anti-clockwise direction
so let's run this
and this is what our donut chart looks
like
so the not murdered
is this dark blue color portion of our
donut chart and when you hold
and when you hover over it you can see
how many values are present in the not
murdered column
the same goes for murdered and because
we've plotted our data in the
anti-clockwise function
this is how it's being plotted so
murdered not murdered and then finally
you have the missing values
the way that you can interpret this
graph is that you can say that most of
the people were murdered during the game
but most of the data is missing so we
can't say for certain whether the
majority of the people were murdered
during the game or not because the
number of missing values can make a huge
difference and the number of people who
were not murdered and the number of
people who were murdered are very close
to each other like their total values
are very close to each other
next we will create a data frame of
sabotages fixed and minutes and change
the column name and add t in them
so this is basically what we're doing
we've created a data frame which has the
number of sabotages fixed and the
minutes
now let's just take the three sabotages
which were fixed which is zero one and
two and create a data frame out of all
of these
so each of these individual data frames
just contains these individual columns
to make a simple scatter plot with only
one legend we can pass the data and use
scatter to make the charts
so basically we're just plotting the
scatter chart in bokeh here
and this is what our minutes
scatter chart looks like
now we're plotting this for one t we're
plotting the minute at which one
sabotage was fixed
and another cool thing about bokeh
charts is that you can always zoom into
them or zoom out of them to better see
where your data is plotted
so this is a scatter chart which has
only one variable which is one t and the
minute at which it was plotted
to make a scatter chart with more
variables
we are going to need to use circle
which is a method of figure object which
we've already seen before
the circle is one of the many plotting
styles which are provided by bokeh you
can also use triangles or many more you
don't have to make each point a circle
so we're gonna be plotting
so we're gonna be plotting the sabotage
is fixed and the minute at which they
were fixed
and we're gonna be plotting three
different circles of three different
colors
i mean each of them correspond to how
many sabotages were fixed at what time
zero sabotages at what time one sabotage
at what time and two at what time so
let's run this
so as you can see here
when zero sabotages were fixed these
were the times
when one was fixed this was the time at
which it was fixed
and when 2 was fixed this is the time
that it was fixed at
now the x-axis is our minutes and the
y-axis is the sabotage
when you hover over it you can see
various information about where each
circle is plotted
so this has an index of 10
the data x y will tell you the
exact x coordinate and the y coordinate
and the screen x y will tell you the
screen pixels on which it is plotted
so now we've taken a look at pie charts
let's move on to histograms
so what exactly is a histogram
histograms are used to plot numerical
data according to the range that they
fall into the data is plotted in the
form of bins or rectangles and the
y-axis corresponds to the amount of data
present in a certain range or at a
certain point
so this is what a histogram looks like
this is a histogram
of the distribution of minutes
so the x-axis has the range
within which this data falls like over
here the first
range is from 0 to 2.9 and second one is
from 2.9 to 5.8
each range
has a
value of 2.9 and the corresponding
y-axis
or the height of the bins
tells us how much data is present within
this range
so this is how you can read histograms
now let's see how we can plot them using
python bouquet now let's see the
distribution of minutes in the among
this game
we will use his to plot a histogram
so basically just going to be plotting
the minutes of our game
we're going to be using the df min
column for this
and we're going to be converting it
into
an integer
so this is the column that we're going
to be plotting let's plot this
again we're going to be using the plot
bokeh
function here
because it makes plotting data frames
very easy
the kind of data frame that we're going
to be using is the histogram or hist
and the title of our
graph is going to be
distribution
of
minutes
so let's run this
now this is what our histogram looks
like
now this is when we've only plotted one
variable which is minutes
yeah so another thing that you can plot
is a stacked histogram
a start histogram is when you plot
various histograms on top of each other
so let's see how this works
for a start histogram we want to see if
the game length has a correlation with
the amount of imposters and crewmates in
our game
so to do this we're going to be creating
a small data frame which has the game
length and the team columns combined
so
let's do that
and this is what this looks like
so all you have to do to plot this in
the form of a stacked histogram is use
the hist function again
so let's see how that is done
and let's give this figure a size of
say
[Music]
750
comma
350
so so let's run this again and this is
the start histogram that you get
we have two different columns which are
plotted on top of each other
uh versus the game length
so basically this tells us that when
game length was between
0 to 0.9 minutes the
number of imposters
was way higher than the number of
crewmates
and
the longer the game went on the number
of imposters decreased and the number of
crewmates just kept getting longer and
longer
now obviously you can say that the
number of crewmates is decreasing as the
game goes on too but this is because the
imposters would have killed off most of
the crewmates
as you can see here towards the end
there are no imposters which means that
most of the imposters were rejected and
the crewmates won
so now we've taken a look at histograms
let's move on to bar plots and
understand how exactly they are
different from histograms
so
in histograms you have plotted numerical
data distributions as of yet
in bar plots you plot for categorical
data it also uses bins to plot the
amount of data when the bins are stored
stacked on top of each other it's called
a stacked bar chart this is basically
what a bar chart looks like the
difference is this does not have its own
range
each bar is used to represent a
categorical data
and the height is used to tell us how
much of that categorical data is present
so now let's see how we can plot a bar
plot
so again we're going to be making a
small data frame of the task completed
and the value counts of how many tasks
have been completed
to plot a bar plot we're going to be
using plot bokeh again and the kind of
plot that we want to plot is bar
so let's run this and see what we get
so here is your bar plot
the task completed in this case is
categorical data
and the counts basically tells us how
many value counts fall into each
category
so zero does completed are 69
one task completed is 117
two tasks completed is 10 and so on
from this bar chart you can say that the
most number of tasks completed is 7 and
the least task completed are 10.
now let's create a start bar chart and
let's see who wins imposters or
crewmates
to create a start bar chart what we're
going to be doing is that we're going to
be creating a different smaller data
frame of team and outcome
to make sure that the bar chart is
stacked all you have to do is include a
start attribute in your bar function and
change its value to true
so let's run this and see
and here you can see that we have a
stacked bar chart
so you can see that crewmates who have a
lot more data have
won
981 times and lost 780 times
while imposters have lost
205 times and won 216 times
so the crewmates have won significantly
far more than the number of times
imposters have won
now let's take a look at stacked
vertical bar charts so so far the bar
charts that we've been looking at have
been horizontal which means that the
data goes upwards
for a vertical bar chart we're gonna be
seeing if all tasks have been completed
or not
so uh in the data frame column all tasks
completed we're gonna be replacing the
values of yes and no with task completed
and task not completed
we're also going to be creating
a smaller data frame of the outcome
column and the task completed column
to plot a start vertical bar chart you
are going to be using
python bokeh dot bar h function
and you're going to be crea
changing the start
attribute to true
this is what a stacked horizontal bar
chart looks like
so over here we can see that the missing
values is represented by blue task
completed by orange and task not
completed by green
here you can see the total outcome you
can see how many wins how many tasks are
completed and how many tasks are not yet
completed
and the same goes for losses you can see
how many losses have occurred how many
tasks were completed and how many tasks
were not completed this is a very good
way of representing a lot of data in a
relatively smaller area
now
the way we can interpret this graph is
that we can say that finishing the task
will automatically
ensure that the crewmates have one so
there's a higher number of people who
need to complete the task to win the
game
another very unique type of bar chart
that you can have is a bi-directional
bar chart
so let's plot a bi-directional
bar chart in which the bars will be
going both ways to the left and to the
right
we're gonna be plotting
a horizontal bar chart over here
to make it easier for you to see
to have
a bidirectional bar chart you need
positive values and negative values the
center
is going to be at zero
so here we're going to be making the
loss features negative by multiplying
the loss feature with the minus one
value
so here we go the losses are all
negatives and the wins are all positives
right now let's run this
and see
how many losses and wins have occurred
for each user
so user1
has 42 losses
and 58 wins but you can easily see
whether they have one more or l or lost
more by comparing the height of the bars
for the wins and the losses
so we can easily say that in this
scenario user one has one more times
than they have lost
the same can be said for user 2 where
the wins bar is significantly higher
than the losses bar
so this is how you can
plot and understand a bi-directional bar
chart
so we've taken a look at how we can plot
bar charts and the various types of bar
charts that are available to us in
python bouquet
now let's take a look at area plots
area plots is a combination of the line
and the bar chart when the area below a
line is shaded
using an area chart we can see how the
values of different groups change over a
period of time
the area chart has different baselines
to show the vertical range of data
here we've
plotted the sabotages fixed versus the
minutes at which they were fixed at
right so these are the minutes and the
sabotages fixed are of two types zero t
and one t
so the number of minutes that we're
considering here is somewhere around 28
ish
right and zero t as you can see has a
way higher value
so one really good thing about area
plots especially in this case is that
they have two ranges
and they have another range on the
y-axis which is still which tells us how
the number of sabotages fixed is ranging
so zero sabotage is fixed you can see
how the value keeps fluctuating and
how the value changes for different
minutes
and the same can be said for one t
now one t has a baseline which is over
here which is just above the zero d
baseline this doesn't necessarily mean
that this is where
one t starts and this is where it ends
this just means that it ranges
from zero all the way here and we can
compare
very easily how zero sabotage is fixed
and one sabotage is fixed range or
change with respect to each other
at
the same time
now the first thing that we're going to
be doing to plot our area chart is that
we're going to be creating
another data frame this is called df
minutes which is going to be comprising
of the minutes column of our data frame
and the sabotage is fixed column of the
same data frame
for df min we're going to be renaming
the columns to 0t and 1t
and the only columns that we're going to
be considering out of the five different
columns that we have are the zero t and
the one t column
we're going to be combining all of these
together in a format which can be
plotted
by using bokeh and column data source
helps us do this it helps us convert
our various
data frame columns into lists
next we're going to be using the figure
function and we're going to give our
figure a width of 400 a height of 400
and the title of sabotage is fixed
versus the minutes at which they were
fixed at
to plot a stat area graph you're going
to be using v area underscore stack
function
from the figure module
you're going to be passing in your y
parameters which is y naught and y one
because we have two different y
parameters here and the x parameter
which is df minutes
the color that you're going to be using
is gray and light gray
the legend labels are the names that
you've already put here which is 0t and
1t
and the source of your data is going to
be this column data source
now let's run this and see how our area
chart looks
so this is our area chart we've got in
two different sabotages here and two
different times
at which they occur which is zero t and
one t
the minutes tells us how many sabotages
were fixed at each time
basically how long it took to fix a
sabotage and a minute during the game at
which they occurred
now let's take a look
at the layout function of our bokeh
library
the layout function will let us build a
grid of plots and wedges we can have as
many rows and columns or grids of plots
in one layout
using the layout function we can see
various graphs at the exact same time
mainly used for designing dashboards it
lets you build grids of plots
so this is basically what your layout
function will help you do
this is going to look very good in a
website because it's going to arrange
our plots in a way that we can easily
see all of them
and understand all of them without any
loss of data
this is also arranged very neatly which
is exactly what the layout functions
allow us to do
so now let's take a look at how the
layout function can be implemented in
python bokeh
now of the layout functions there are
many different layout options which are
available
you have the column function which
allows you to display
plots vertically
and you have the grid function which
lets you display plots in the form of
grids
now for example
let's say that we want to make a
dashboard layout in bokeh
we are going to be considering
three different charts
the first one that we're gonna be
considering is a lollipop chart which is
done here
the next one that we're going to be
considering are two pie charts
so this is how you plot a lollipop chart
and i'll show you what exactly a
lollipop chart is in just a minute the
first thing that you need to know is
that the first graph that we're going to
be plotting
is going to be a graph which has the
user id versus the outcome of the games
plotted
on it
so what we're going to be doing here is
that we're going to be creating a single
data frame which has
all of the
user ids present in it along with the
user
and the wins that the user has obtained
now using this we're going to be
plotting it in the form of
a plot in decreasing order where we have
the top 10 users who have one
which basically means that the users who
have won the most number of games out of
all the users in consideration
so figure one segment will basically
help you plot
a line which has a width of two and a
circle will be at the circle at the very
top of this segment so lollipop chart is
going to be
a horizontal line with a circle at the
very top
so the next graph that we're going to be
plotting is going to be a murdered
and not murdered and missing values pie
chart
and the last thing that we're going to
be plotting is a donut chart of the
teams
and the values within them
so these are the three different graphs
that we're going to be plotting and
these are just us creating the graphs
and plotting them
the main logic is over here
the main logic is that you want to set a
layout in bokeh
as to how you want to see the charts
so the layout that we are going to be
looking at is that we're going to be
having a lollipop chart at the very top
and two smaller pie charts at the bottom
right
so
we have three figures here
and the first thing that we're going to
be doing is that we're going to be
giving these
figures
a line color of none
the axis is not going to be visible and
the axis labels are not present for
these figures
this is the main function that you're
going to be looking at this is your
layout using the grade layout function
that you've imported here from python
from bokeh dot layouts you're going to
be creating a grid
and how does the grid know where the
figures are
so you've divided the grid into two this
is evident because you have two figures
two main figures here
which are separated by a comma so this
tells the grid that the page is going to
be divided into two
the first figure which is on top is
going to be figure 1 and the figure at
the bottom are figure 2 and 3
this means that the bottom half is going
to be further split into
vertically
let's run this and see what our layout
looks like
so here you have it your entire page is
divided into two
the first one has one the figure one
which is the lollipop chart and the
bottom half of our page
has two figures which are the two donut
charts
the bottom half is divided exactly into
two as you can see here
this is because that is the grid layout
that we wanted
so this is how you can use the layout
function in
python bokeh it is extremely easy all
you have to do is create a layout by
using the grid function or you can also
use the column function the column
function will
plot it
in the form of a single column
vertically
using the grid function you can plot
figures vertically as shown here
so when you separate them by commas with
respect to each other they will be plot
but they will be plotted vertically and
when you group them together
and separate them with commas internally
they will be plotted horizontally
so now we've taken a look at how we can
use the layout function
now let's see how we can make
interactive graphs with the help of
bokeh
over here we're going to be using bokeh
to design a dashboard which is used to
represent the horsepower in cars
we are also going to make our graphs
interactive and see how maximum
information can be conveyed with the
help of a single graph
so here we have multiple different cars
and along with the cars will also be
going to be given their horse bars
a little bit of other information about
them and their images
and over here as you can see
we have a very simple
vertical bar chart
but let's see how we can make it
interactive and convey all the
information that we have in our single
data set on this one bar graph
so the first thing that we're going to
be doing is importing all of our
important necessary modules we're
obviously going to have the pandas
modules which is going to be imported to
work with the data frame that we've
given
apart from this we're also going to be
importing
figures output file show save and column
data source from bokeh.plotting we
already know that the figure function is
used to plot different types of graphs
which are given
output file is just used to see our file
the show is used to display our graphs
and save will help you save your graph
now the column data source is the core
of most bokeh plots
it provides the data to the glyph of
your plot when you pass sequences like
python lists or numpy arrays to a bokeh
render bokeh automatically creates a
column data source with this data for
you so this is basically what you're
going to be using to pass data onto your
bokeh glyphs
apart from this we're also going to be
using a harvard tool function
and
a trans and from the transform function
we're going to be importing factor c map
we're going to be importing a palette
color
which is going to be various shades of
blue
and we're going to be importing
components from the embedded function of
bokeh
let's just see how we can use all of
these and the different things that they
do
the first thing that you're going to be
doing is reading in your car's data
frame and creating a column data source
so that you can easily pass this data
onto your
bokeh glyphs
so let's run
and import all of our various required
functionalities and import the data as
well
so this is what your data set looks like
we have eight different values in our
data set which are the names of
different cars their horsepower their
price and a hyperlink of an image
this is what our data set looks like we
have only eight columns so using this
data set we are going to be plotting a
horizontal bar graph
again we're going to be
calling our figure function and we're
going to be giving y range to our car
list
the y range is basically just going to
have the different values which are
going to be present on the y axis we've
given the blot a width of 800 and a
height of 600
the title of the plot is cars with top
horsepower and the x-axis label is horse
bar
the tools that we're using here is pan
box select zoom in zoom out save and
reset so these are tools that you're
going to be getting on the right side of
your plot
now let's render our glyph or render our
graph
the graph that we are going to be using
here is the horizontal bar graph so the
y axis is going to have cars
and the right or basically the height of
the entire bar is going to depend on the
horsepower
the left is going to start from 0 and
the height of each bar is going to be
0.4
the color that we are going to be giving
is going to be a palette of blue so each
different car will have a different
color of blue associated with it and the
color of blue which is associated with
it will depend on the
car list
now fill alpha 0.9 the source is your
source data that you have over here
which is the column data source of our
data frame
and the legend is going to be car which
basically means that your entire uh
plot is going to have the legend of car
now we're going to be adding the legend
this is
us giving the legend its orientation so
the legend is going to be vertically
oriented the location is going to be on
the top right and the font size of the
text car of a legend is going to be 10
px or 10 pixels
we're also going to be adding a hover
tool
inside this harvard tool
this hover tool tips will basically tell
you what you're going to be seeing
in the harvard tool box
so we're going to be creating this with
the help of an html format
the first thing that you're going to be
seeing is the name of the car
the next
column will have the price of the car
the horsepower of the car
and the image
now the image is in the form of a
hyperlink and this is going to be auto
populated in your hover tool
the width of the image is going to be
800
so
we are going to add all of these hover
tools to our p image and we are finally
going to be showing you the graph and
what it looks like
so this is your bouquet plot here the
name the title of the plot is cars with
top horsepower this is your
legend which is cars
the name of each car is given here along
with the color which is associated with
it here are the different tools that we
have
you can save this
you can reset it you can zoom out you
can zoom in
you can select the boxes
and you can pan your image
so here we're zooming in here we're
zooming out
if we save this the plot automatically
gets
downloaded in your system and if you
reset it the image goes back to exactly
what it looked like when it was first
opened
now here you have the names of the
different cars on the y-axis and you
have the various horsepowers on the
x-axis
let's take a look at a harvard tool
so here you have the name of the car
which is on top you have the price and
you have the horse bar and as you can
see you have the image which is hyper
pop which is populated instantly from
the hyperlink that was available to us
now the color palette associated with
each car
gets darker the more the horsepower of
the car increases
so here we have cars with top
horsepowers
which are arranged in an
ascending order from the top and a
descending order from the bottom
so this is another way that you can use
bokeh to create extremely interactive
and informational graphs
here in just half a page and this is us
making a huge plot right we can also
decrease the size of the plot if you
want to but basically in half a page
we've conveyed all the information
ranging from the name of the car to its
model to the horsepower that is ha that
it has its price and also its image
and this is also very good way to
compare it
so these are just some functionalities
which are provided in bokeh itself no
other
data visualization library will let you
work
so well
with graphs and will let you customize
your graphs to this extent
and with that we come to the end of this
video on python data visualization
we hope you enjoyed this video if you
did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated
also here's your reminder to subscribe
to our channel and click on the bell
icon for more on the latest technologies
and trends
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simplyla
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here